so let's zoom in on some sweat that
might be on the surface of your skin and
zoom in at a molecular level so we're
zooming in at a super super super close
up level over here and what we've done
is we've drawn the skin and each of
those circles you can imagine is a
molecule of skin so we're even going
into the subcellular level right over
here and and i've oversimplified it but
it'll hopefully give you the idea and
each of these things right over here is
a molecule of water the blue is the is
the oxygen atom and then the whites are
the hydrogen atoms h2o i could even
write it like this h you have two h's
and you have an oxygen this each of
these is a molecule of water
what we perceive as temperature is
really just the kinetic energy of these
molecules so each of these molecules
both on our skin and this water are in
the sweat which is mainly water they're
all bumping around and moving around and
they all have a certain amount of
kinetic energy movement energy some of
that they're moving in a certain
direction some of it might be
vibrational they're also rotating and
that total average kinetic energy that's
what we perceive as temperature so all
of these are moving around as well
now what we see is temperature is just
the average but all of them might be
moving around in different they all have
different individual energies some might
be bumping around faster vibrating more
vibrating less it changes as they bump
into each other so when you have water
or sweat on the surface of your skin
what's happening is let's say your skin
keeps getting heated up because your
muscles down here someplace keep
releasing energy so these things get
they start moving around more and more
and bouncing around and vibrating around
as they do that they transfer some of
their energy to the water so the more
that these bump around they're going to
eventually bump into this water and then
the water will have high energy and so
they will start bumping around more so
you might say okay fair enough my
muscles warm up my skin and the skin
warms up the water but i don't see any
heat being released and the key here is
is the idea that these water molecules
on average might have we could view it
as a temperature but on an individual
molecular basis they all have a
different kinetic energy that one might
be going really fast in that direction
this one might be going really slow and
what you're going to have happening all
of these water molecules they are
attracted to each other those are called
hydrogen bonds we talk about them in
more depth in the chemistry playlist but
if they have enough energy if they're
going in just the right direction they
might be able to escape so they all have
they all are attracted to each other
they are attracted to each other a
little bit and that's why the water kind
of the water to some degree sticks
together so they are
they are attracted to each other a
little bit but if one of these molecules
has enough energy they can break free
and so the question is well which
molecules are going to break free well
the molecules are going to break free
are the ones that have the highest
energy or an average or most likely the
molecules that are most likely to break
free so let's say it's we have a
molecule right over here
if it has enough energy if it has enough
energy and it's going in the right
direction let's say this one has a lot
of energy and it's going in that
direction it might actually break free
and go essentially evaporate become
water vapor and go and just escape from
this little droplet of sweat
and so if the if the molecules that have
the highest velocity the highest average
highest kinetic energy are the ones that
are most likely to break free what's
going to happen is these break free well
you have all your highest energy
particles or highest energy molecules is
the one that break free so those are
leaving then the average of what's left
over is going to have a lower average
kinetic energy or a lower temperature so
in a molecular scale what's happening is
is that you could view it as the the the
hottest particles are the ones that are
most likely to leave so you transfer
energy to them they bounce around the
hottest ones leave they're the ones that
most are most likely to escape and so
they take all of that energy with them
and so whatever's left over will have on
average lower energy or a lower
temperature so hopefully that makes
sense it's all about the heat getting
transferred from your muscle to the
skins to the water and then the
evaporation of the water is taking the
most energetic particles away and
allowing the whole the rest of
everything else to cool down